FA Cup semi-final de 1989 one of the
biggest games of the season and the fans
just wanted to get in and see the
football the senior policeman in charge
of keeping them all safe had only been
given the role of match commander 19
days earlier David duckenfield had
already briefed his officers inside
Hillsborough Stadium he didn't really
know he could have had no idea that
three decades on he'd be standing trial
each and every one of his decisions
scrutinized in court the 30 year wait
for justice has hurt every family
Karen Harrison lost her husband Gary
that day changed me totally as opposed
and I've just missed but I felt good
about with him for these clean and poor
their daughter Claire was just eight
when she lost her dad there's birthdays
important birthdays that have been
missed my wedding day
he's number two granddaughters and it's
just all things that eve of loves have
been a part of that he will never be a
part of her dad Gary alongside his
brother Steven were in the crowds trying
to get into the turnstiles at the
Leppings Lane and ten minutes before
kickoff an exit gate gate C was opened
hundreds of fans streamed in
but the Liverpool fans had not broken
down the gates the match commander David
duckenfield had given the instruction to
open it that decision transferred the
overcrowding from outside to inside the
stadium instinctively the fans moved to
the central tunnel down towards the pens
behind the goal David duckenfield should
have closed the tunnel off but he didn't
to the right of the goal the match
commentator John Watson spotted the
problem to the right of there that's it
down there as the match kicked off the
crush in the central pens became
unbearable survivors said it felt like a
vice getting tighter and tighter the
police who were there was simply
overwhelmed it was absolute bedlam there
was there was nobody in charge people
were being pushed left right and centre
it was a police had just gone to base
there was no control no orders had been
getting through mr. duggenfield did make
mistakes that day even tried to blame
the Liverpool fans for what happened but
the jury decided that his
decision-making back in 1989 did not
meet the high threshold of being grossly
negligent David duckenfield only
acknowledged his lie at the inquests
that concluded in 2016 the families felt
that established the truth the trial has
been about accountability and it's only
been possible because of a comprehensive
review of everything that happened when
I'm watching the footage and I'm seeing
people outside the ground
spectators going in and I identify
somebody that's half an hour late has
probably lost their life in the back of
my mind I keep saying to myself stop
turn around do
go through that gate don't go through
that turnstyle don't head towards the
tunnel Brian Matthews was one of the 96
he was a bank manager
his widow Maggie has always believed
that justice goes far beyond just David
duckenfield don't think one man can be
the figure had all the whipping boy for
the hell of the year the tragedy that
unfolded I don't hate the man I don't
hate so anyone I feel dreadfully sorry
from right now the age he's got to and
he's lived with this for 30 years I mean
I wouldn't like to swap his mind his
thoughts as emotions for anything in the
world
David duckenfield acquittal means he is
now free to continue his life but what
happened at Hillsborough will in all
likelihood never leave him
Tom Parmenter Sky News